the handouts a courtesy of Russia's
military after bombing much of this
country into submission swinging the war
in President Bashar al-assad's favor
they're now the great providers keen to
show their humanitarian side Russia is
with you is what's written on these
plastic bags
this is karna shakuni in southern Italy
recently recaptured by Assad's forces
[Music]
it was here two years ago that the
regime dropped what was thought to be
sarin gas on its own people an attack so
appalling us launched with territory
airstrikes its first direct military
intervention in this eight-year war but
don't mention the crimes of Syria's
President here in the nearby town of
Saran we're met by all singing at Assad
supporting crowds soundtrack to a hollow
victory via manhood I mean a man and he
there is the other side of the frontline
the remaining part of Idlib province
which still eludes President Assad now
largely in the hands of the jihadist
group High Italian we're on a Russian
military press tour just a few miles
here from the front line
they show us tunnels recently vacated by
opposition fighters complete with a
workshop for producing drones even a
prison and solitary confinement cell
along the way through the windows of our
armored vehicle mile after mile of
deserted towns and villages flattened as
the regime advanced into Whitlam for now
a month-old ceasefire is holding the
Assad's forces still have plenty of
fight left in them these are new
recruits on exercise near Damascus but
ready for deployment north of Falana
well and yet Mahayana say no daddy hi
Edna
women huh Douglas Surya I'm puff Rossiya
that Alec ml geography Sharia way
afternoon o'clock bo Samantha
as for Russia it has what it wants in
Syria the Mayim airbase tank Tartus
Naval facility and a return to the
influence it held in Cold War times the
fighter jets which pounded rebel-held
areas are fewer than they were but
they're still flying for all the
military prowess and strong foothold now
in the Middle East there is the
reconstruction of this country which
Russia certainly does not have the
economic wherewithal for and the process
of reconciliation which it is
questionable whether the Assad regime
has the political will for we're taken
to Aleppo past what's left of what was
the rebel-held East decimated in the
four-year fight for this city volunteers
are making a start on the famous Old
Market News Center Chuck since 2012 a 15
year old boy in the Moscow t-shirt does
his bit for the cameras in amongst all
this rubble it is surprised to turn a
corner and see one section beautifully
restored
produced from our minders but sanctions
should be lifted refugees should return
but there's a Breitling future here but
as Syria and its neighbors agitate for
refugees to come home aid groups warn of
detentions and disappearances of
recruitment to the Armed Forces
the Syrian network of Human Rights
estimates that 2000 returnees have gone
missing since 2017 happen after a Baba
Nikolaevna melanoma Aladin fizzle kudu
are homeless kanoun el Hedorah local
noon Yanni and the surah def in surah
al-baqarah surah al-baqarah afternoon
but for too many it is not that there
are only ruins to return to it is that
there is a leader they have no reason to
trust Diana Magnay Sky News Concha kun
Syria